[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul and if you're having
chip problems i feel bad for your son
i got 99 clown forces a bad batch ain't
one hit me
no go on actually hit me now episode 7
is out worldwide on disney plus
and in this video we're going to be
breaking down all the easter eggs
hidden details and things you missed in
the show we'll of course be giving our
crazy theories on where things could be
going
as well as a review on the series so
make sure you stick around
until the end all now there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to check it out then i'll
see you darth later
make sure you like the video if you
enjoy it and don't forget to subscribe
to make sure i'll seat you back
the the next now that was one of the
worst ones we've ever done
and without the way let's get into the
video okay so in episode 6 we saw as the
bad batch journeyed out to corellia to
take the head of a tactical droid
in order to achieve info that would help
them to defeat the clone troopers
they ended up running into some of the
most beloved star wars characters of all
time
but they weren't actually that bad to be
fair and instead of taking the plans for
themselves the batch left them in the
capable hands of the uprising rebels
the episode ended with the martez
sisters reaching out to a mysterious
contact
and i've been kicking myself for the
last week about how i said it could have
been ahsoka
but the subtitles for the episode said
it was a he i also had a lot of comments
saying that r7 was destroyed at the end
of the clone wars
but we did see it shell there for a
reason and it was clearly kept so
i do think that it was fixed up and
given to the sisters
for them to be so closely linked to
ahsoka and for there to also be a droid
called r7 that has the exact same colors
it just seems too much of a coincidence
now we'll talk about this later on in
the video but another important thing to
bear in mind
is that wrecker's chip actually
activated at one point in the episode
he said the words good soldiers follow
orders which are synonymous with what
the clones uttered during the aftermath
of order 66.
if you cast your mind back at the clone
wars then you might remember that ahsoka
actually helped to find and take out
captain rex's chip
and this idea of taking out the chips
when the chips are down
definitely plays into this entry now
episode 7 is called battle scores which
typically refers to a wound suffered in
battle that serves as somewhat of a
reminder
for example people showcase their own
battle scores when telling stories
and they're very much a reminder of what
someone has been through
in the case of the bad batch it's used
to denote what's left behind after the
chips are removed
and these scores serve as a reminder
that the bad batch are now free
we pick up with them getting chased by
some rokai after stealing a rare and
valuable lizard
that we learn is called ruby due to the
hyperdrive not being online
they are unable to carry out a light
speed jump and this is similar to what
happened to the millennium falcon during
empire
actually like that it's just not easy to
jump straight to light speed in order to
solve problems
and they actually face some difficulties
one thing i did feel about the sequel
trilogy is that they overuse
light speed quite a lot and i actually
find the scenes way more tense when they
don't just have a get out of jail free
card
echo and wreckers strap themselves in
and the lizard grabs onto rekka's head
almost like a facehugger which is
another nod to aliens
the mandalorian 2 did something similar
with grogu
and throughout the series so far there's
been several callbacks to that franchise
they make the jump to light speed and go
back to sids
who as we guessed has very much become
their agent who sends them out on
missions
i did say that i think she'll be the
seasons grief koga and though he and
mando weren't on good terms for for the
majority of that first season
she's gonna be here supplying them with
jobs constantly to pay for the money
that they owe her
sid is clearly ripping them off and
charging them overheads while
sending them out on missions making it
so that it's going to be difficult for
them to actually make enough to break
away from her
and thus they're probably going to be
stuck in this life for a while
sid is a transition which is the same
species as bosque
and as a whole they're known as slippery
characters
in the bar we catch the idorian and we
quay again and we can see they're
playing dejarik
which is the holochess game that you
probably saw in a new hope
we heard that wookies were known for
being bad losers when it came to this
and that they'd leave people pretty
armless like harmless
meaning they couldn't do anything now a
mysterious hooded figure has followed
them to the bar
and shout out simone berman on twitter
for pointing out that this is very
similar to how aragorn was introduced in
the fellowship of the rings
this is captain rex who it turns out was
the contact from last week
we last heard him name dropped in
episode 2 when we discovered from the
queen that he'd passed through his home
recently
and since the ending of clone wars he's
left ahsoka's side
i'm guessing that he fixed up r7 and
gave it to the martez sisters
but again that's just me making
assumptions and you should never
assume as it makes an ass out of you and
me now he's approached by the two
regulars
and this is somewhat similar to when dr
cornelius evazan and baba
started a fight with luke that left the
latter pretty armless eh
say that good jokes are good now we also
hear of a brand new snack called mantel
mix
which is named after the planet or
mantel this is served by an
alien that simon says could be from
pantora
which was the home of baron papanoider
interestingly this character was
actually played by george lucas in a
cameo role
and whether this species is the same or
not i still think that's a nice little
bit of trivia
for your [ __ ] ass now sid says she's
got a big job for them
one that will make things right from
them letting go of the tactical droid
last week
she never actually tells them what it is
but we do know that coming down the line
there'll be something they can do
that basically sets them up for life and
means they can evade the empire forever
rex takes his head off in a scene that
echoes when obi-wan did it in a new hope
luke has also done something similar
when reintroducing himself
and again it's like poetry they rhyme i
think this dress may have been inspired
by ahsoka
who the last we saw of her was wearing
something similar to what he does here
at several points in the scene we catch
the score where rex's chip was removed
and displays massively into the events
that unfold
we learn he's been keeping a low profile
and that he's actually listed as kia
in the imperial files now we do know
what happens to the character
due to his appearance and later
properties and i love how they've sort
of reconned him into being one of the
soldiers in return of the jedi
rex is a great character and i hope that
we get more of him in the series
when rekka walks in we can also catch a
digital version of sabok to the left of
the screen
and this card game is infamous
throughout star wars lore
rex tells omega he's never met a clone
like her before
and this further hints towards something
being different about her
after rekka's head plays up he becomes
worried that they haven't removed their
chips
and it's so dangerous he's willing to
kill them on the off chance that they
could activate
rex's chip obviously activated during
the clone wars
and he almost killed his closest ally
because of it
he goes off to bracket to find out a way
to remove theirs
and this is a junkyard planet where
ships are sent to be decommissioned
if you play jedi fall in order you will
no doubt recognize the planet
as the place that kyle kesters worked at
when lying low from the imperials
he was part of the scrapper guild who we
learn now operate in the area
omega confirms that she hasn't got a
chip in her head and once more this puts
her above the typical grunt
now one thing i forgot to mention last
week is that the empire actually
decommissioned the entire droid army
in order to use the scraps to build new
ships and fleets
braka is more of a starship graveyard
and inside one of the down cruisers they
go to a medical facility
in order to remove the chips however
it's not as easy as it seems
and within the water we get our second
lord of the rings reference with a giant
creature lurking beneath it
similar to the watcher outside the minds
of moria wrecker refuses to cross the
cable over a gorge at one point
further tying into his fear of heights
and after the rope snaps he gets pulled
in by the creature i love how this robe
is yellow
as typically it's a color used in games
didn't know the way forward
and with this being a location that
people have played on
it's like poetry they they i don't know
i don't even know if they do anymore now
if you turn on the subtitles you'll see
that this beast is a dianoga
which you'll probably know is the thing
that grabbed luke in the death star
it was also a boss in shadows of the
empire and these creatures tend to live
on board ships in their trash compactors
explaining its appearance here there's a
mention of calla
as well as caleb june from episode 1 who
would later go on to be one of the key
characters in rebels
we see a space rat and omega worries
that the surgery won't go well
this might hint towards her being able
to sense the incoming danger
and rekka activates and starts to go
full clone trooper on them
he calls them traitors and chases them
throughout the whole of the ship
attempting to murder them for standing
up to the empire
it's a great extremely tense scene and
you can see that they are using stun
blasts on him
but you should have done that first now
omega shoots at him
and i kinda thought that the stun she
took looked a lot like ripley in
aliens but might just be seeing
similarities for the sake of it there
either way this sets off wrecker and he
chases her through the corridors
but she's able to outmaneuver him the
homie simon pointed out that this is a
direct opposite to the start of the
entry
when the pair were just having fun with
one another omega doesn't want to hurt
wrecker
and he grabs the gun off her before
saying good soldiers follow orders
which again is something that the clones
uttered upon carrying out order 66
rekka is stunned and the chip is removed
but it takes a while for him to gain
consciousness
i was kind of hoping that in the series
he would come across ahsoka and then
have it activate
but unfortunately it doesn't look like
that's gonna happen and it's gonna just
be
a fan theory that i've failed to get
right however this clearly shows they
can remove the chip from crosshair
and i think that when they go to do this
they'll probably knock him out
beforehand so that the same thing
doesn't happen
the show is very much about free will
versus conformity
and giving wrecker free will here shows
that he's now become a better person
the chips are taken out of them and
bandages are put over the wounds
which all line up exactly with where
rex's battle score was
wrecker said he had no choice and tried
to make it stop but couldn't
but omega says it's okay and gives him
some mental mix
rex and hunter go and get some air and
the former tries to recruit them
but he says that he has to do what's
best for his squad rex leaves but hunter
says he'll be there if they're ever in
trouble
so we can expect to see him again
unfortunately the scrapper guild sees
them
and they notify the empire i think that
next time potentially crosshair will
arrive
and that they will capture him and take
his chip out it's going to be difficult
for them to escape the planet
and who knows they might even include
cal and have him help the group out
either way really fun entry and lots to
look forward to
for the mid-season episode now as for my
thought on the show so far
i know it's getting a bit of a lukewarm
reception
like a torn torn but i'm still really
enjoying it
i think the best way that i describe the
show is that it's solid
now what i mean by that is you very much
know what you're getting week-to-week
and though i don't think it's absolutely
mind-blowing all the time
it's a really nice side tangent into the
star wars universe
i really wish that we were getting more
crosshair stuff as he's probably the
most
interesting character for me in the show
and that's purely because with him we're
seeing the rise of the empire
through the eyes of a soldier working
within its ranks this is completely
unexplored
and though we have seen people uprising
against the empire on the outside of it
we've not really seen the day-to-day
workings of it through someone who's
internally part of the organization
i think there's potential there for an
amazing character study on someone who's
gone from fighting for what was
essentially freedom
to becoming someone who has to oppress
others in order to keep them in line
the batch hardly seem to even be
bothered about saving him and it does
sort of dampen the brotherhood that they
have
when he's been so easy to forget now we
still have nine episodes left in the
season
so there is plenty of time to explore
that more i just hope that they get
around to it
as for this one again another solid
edition that i think just keeps building
the show is something worth coming back
for each and every week
it's a wrap on the video but i'd of
course love to hear your thoughts and
theories in the comments below
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
store on the 30th of june
in which we're giving away three copies
of the mcu phase three box set
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode the winners of
last month's competition are on screen
right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter at heavyspoilers you want
something else to watch them make sure
you check out our breakdown of the first
episode of loki
which will be linked on screen right now
we went over the entire show and pointed
out all the easter eggs that you need to
know about it
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more by the way
thank you for sticking through the video
i've been paul and the force will be
with you
always take care peace